hello everyone i'm alan and welcome to
my channel where today i am very excited
to be playing lost in random i do have
to tell you this video is sponsored by
ea but if you've seen any of the videos
where i've spoken about this game the ea
originals program or zoink games in
general who are the devs you'd know that
i was going to play it anyway and then i
was very excited about it honestly very
happy to be involved
so from what i know about lost in random
this one that you know we're going to
dive into going to play some of it this
is fresh i have not touched it prior to
right now this is obviously as it says
here not a final version of the game the
final version of the game comes out
september 10th but it's uh the newest
game single player action adventure
very interested in the art style if you
saw my ea play conference reactions it
definitely focused a lot on that but i
also think the gameplay looks very
interesting so
let's jump into it
okay
ah yes
a die long ago in a land you might
remember from your dreams the power of
randomness was celebrated by all those
with dice would roll them to shape their
destinies
where my dnd players at
[Music]
i don't think i play as the dice though
i think the dice is called dicey
oh my god
it me i say about any character who has
white hair
it i didn't know i was in the video game
get the dice energy okay
let's get that energy
okay let's do it
okay i need some more that was super
rude
where's the last bit where's the lost oh
okay i should attack them
wow the sound design is
very good
okay so we got a card now how does this
work leave dimension
oh dice mentioned no no sorry that was
wrong
i have summoned
heavy a thing and that's what the cod
did for me i think is what that means
okay
[Music]
watch out
i'm just very interested in the lore
implications you know okay i thought
this would be a flashback or something
like all errors it too would come to an
end
fading into legend and mystery
until now
too many pressure plates to stand on
that's gonna be some puzzles sounds like
puzzles to me later
in onecroft
a small village populated entirely by
people who have never once been dealt a
fair hand
attention
i am the queen and my dark dice will
decide your fate random rule
the kids when i was in high school were
all about things being random
there was this period of time where it
was like that's so random
that i've been missed
for the rest of my time
you're a dirty three doomed to a life of
fighting and misery
well so is having an almighty dice snake
eye
stop you guys wrap this up we should
really get going it's just a game sis i
love this art style
oh my gosh
it's like
very
fairy tale fantasy gothic
hey was that really necessary come on
hurry up they are all a lot happier than
you'd think they would be considering
these circumstances this seems like a
pretty bad place to be
i remember these from the conference
but i don't remember what it is except
that i okay i didn't expect to hate it
that much it's very spider-like
not a huge fan okay
oh no
oh
any oh man you know i know i'm
australian but i am very afraid of
spiders and i get this like
terrible
chill anytime i see anything that's
oh boy okay
we're off to a start
i do think we could run a little bit
faster
oh god okay shoot it with this
i feel like you want me to shoot this
thing
incredible cool
number
come on let's get out of here oh my
everybody's everybody we're just running
through people's homes and everybody's
scared they live in teapots
they live in teapots i'm sorry that i'm
walking over your teapots while you're
all very sad about the giant spider
things that's super rude of me
[Music]
that's nanny for tuna works for the
queen kidnapping children for
so the her
decreed that any child who had reached
the age of 12
would be given the grand honor of
rolling her one true oh my what's this i
see something over here what is that
is that something
check out this secret portal bring me
all of the children
an old crawl space
what is this
let's go or the queen's
since she is and ever shall be
damn i hope somebody talks about me that
way one day
of emotion when you watch your children
move to them
yeah that's pretty sad dude
i would love to have somebody speak on
behalf of me that day but that way one
day
jeez
no i think we should all leave random
did random do this because if so random
sucks actually
oh my
even odd where have you been we've been
worried sick i'm sorry dad i try to
there's no time she'll be here any
minute
quick get down
to steal your kids because we're 12.
happy birthday oh
even
and i got a present for you they're
about to be orphans aren't they so cute
make a wish
it would just finish the story so
beautifully if you end up orphaned it's
just it to be so on point you know
and the queen said every child of 12
years shall throw this supreme dice and
so it was for random is fair random
prevails and rendering i don't know that
random is fair
be grateful child that the queen herself
you could make a case for it
oh
oh she's sort of hot
i didn't expect her to
i'll go with you yeah
you can give me a makeover
damn
if that hey if that's all it takes for
me to get to hang out with you i will
roll your dice madam
now roll the dice and let's see what
kind of person you truly are
what does it mean
what does it mean
it had been settled what does it mean
[Music]
came to be living by the side of the
queen up in the sixers palace where it
was said all dreams came oh so that's
how like they picked the upperclass man
was just beginning
wow not an often though so
you win some you lose some
could be worse
i would like to go see her again though
you know just
maybe see if she has a boyfriend just
sort of check in on the situation with
that you know
i'm coming for you
this is very pretty i i'm a big fan of
the art style i think um
one of the other zoink games flipping
death definitely has this sort of like
gothic e aesthetic
a little bit
where is this right now it's a little
bit more like fey which i think they
pronounce is fair
lots of uh
neoni kind of stuff going on
in any case i'm a big fan it looks great
[Music]
am i dreaming
wait wait don't i play as even
oh my
oh my oh oh boy okay
so about causing a deck when you so and
i think it's like a cod collecting game
as well which is very cool
more than a year had passed since her
sister had been taken away from her and
in all that time
even had never dreamed like that before
even knew she was now awake and knew
this was the same house she'd lived in
her entire life something seemed off i
also really liked the narrative it
seemed
different or was it simply that she had
changed
this is a good vibe
these fairy tale vibes they feel good
okay
oh a portrait of uncle jinx it was said
he'd sailed the seven seas
that's very cute a painting of aunt
cordelia
she could play every single musical
instrument in one craft which was
impressive but an image oh i cut him off
sorry sir great grandmother waters
she was the woman who'd invented sliced
bread
oh very good before then they'd just
taken great big bites somebody had to
come up with it you know somebody had to
do it
an image of great great grandfather
peters
200 years ago he ate all his clothing to
win a bet even supposed that was the
reason this portrait stopped at the
neckline
very
cute i mean this is a massive house dude
like i get that
the suggestion is that you're in the
slums but also
even are you always painted and she'd
share with even the stories she'd hidden
in her paintings wonderful tales of
daring heroines and dashing adventures
she'll upset she told her never to share
these stories with the outside world
these stories might
upset the queen and she had eyes and
ears everywhere
okay shoes
little parts of her life still dotted
their house that is pretty sad actually
make it a happy house but that was fine
by even
she never wanted to forget her sister
these paintings showed stories evens
mother told her were safe to share
because they were true
so she said
like the story of the card makers of
five town who'd suffered a horrible fate
this is some real
dictator business we got going on here
what's this
even's father never told her stories
he preferred reality to fantasy
the physicality of hammers and nails to
the ephemeral but these are books
and fantasy i suspect he did not write
the books
they just happen to be here
[Music]
oh it was still very late or was it very
early
and even didn't want to wake her parents
i'm very into this vibe so far is what i
will say it's very nice okay
the scariest painting even's mother had
ever made was of the shadow man
a mysterious figure would gobble up
children who ventured too far from home
right yup was too old to believe in such
stories
or at least that's what she taught
herself
very very very taily all of it is i mean
this house is
gorgeous
i'm into the narrator i'm a big fan of
all the the color and all the lighting
going on
see if we can get into more of that
gameplay though it's um
definitely a combination of of dice
battles time freezing card collection
you battle inside a giant kind of board
game arenas
which is very interesting to me it
sounds super
unique even stared at the toy feeling
the ground tilt beneath her
back somebody left it there exact same
stuff
that was the present she was taken
even knew her parents would be
heartbroken when they woke and found her
missing
but she had to go
she had to know you could i mean we
could leave a note for them maybe you
don't well
okay okay we could leave a note though
you don't we don't have to just
go all out
okay
i don't think i can jump so i'm going to
assume none of that is climbable
[Music]
though seem to keep its distance from
even
when she got closer it moved further
away can i smash the boxes
somewhere
yeah
oh my gosh look at you
hello there even what are you doing out
so darn late you're running like the old
witch uma put a curse on you
oh i didn't know that it was gonna have
dialogue options um
keep it big keep it big
you're thinking about your sister aren't
you
i feel your child
i do
but she's been gone now a year
um to be super nice i'm not gonna be
mean to astrid she seems lovely though i
don't know what she's doing here in your
eye tells me you're not fooling around
i remember being your age once i do
and i know how important imagination can
seem all right all right i'll get out of
your way
but don't tell your parents you saw me
deal
thanks astrid you're the best quite
welcome young miss even
and stay away from the outskirts we'll
do we'll do gotcha boss
okay
i really want to break all these boxes
but i'm not going to
we are going to find
the
ghost wait please just wait
this was onecroft the world in which
even and her small family lived like all
warner's they hauled junk for the cargo
ships that came and went in the night
all this labor was done for reasons that
were never clearly understood the queen
wielded and no one would dare a poser
and that was enough for everyone i'm
very into this
it is
except even
i think this lore is fantastic in this
world building
i'm very into it
friends come on just hit it it's right
there hey guys
what are you doing here anyway yeah even
are your parents letting you out after
dark now
honestly even i gotta say i'm impressed
never thought you had it in you to break
a precious rule wow
lucky thanks alcohol
that was a compliment
i think you're cool even even if you
should listen to your parents more
my parents say listening to them is the
coolest thing of all
you guys are so touchy
uh
why are you all out so late i couldn't
sleep my 12th birthday is coming up yeah
you just get ripped away from your
family huh gonna get to roll the dice
when it comes i'm gonna be a sixer
so everyone wants to be a sixer
they
you getting a load of these bloobs even
uh well we don't know she could be happy
up there actually we could be trying to
save your sister
from like something she's stoked about
so
have we thought about that have we
considered that as a possibility even
well that's just her bad luck not the
sort of thing i've ever had to worry
about
really
how come because my name is lucky and he
meant how come even thinks it didn't
work out lucky
uh yeah let's do this
i think she might be sending me a
message like a sixer would ever care
about her wanna you please oh we we we
really do live in a society they paying
taxes up there
one percent did they buy three million
dollar houses with your cool mystery
even see you later
hey thanks um there was something to
shoot right
this
oh cool
money
i feel like i'm getting money
hey get ready to die trying that's
that's what i always say
everybody just sort of hangs out
[Music]
these look a lot he looks a lot like my
dad brothers mayhaps
where did it go oh it's over there okay
but i still don't want to well okay
let's check the journal end map
spa by a remarkable dream even such a
house full of something and soon she'd
found it the old the toy should give an
odd on her birthday on that horrible day
she was taken left for her by a strange
and glowing figure
oh what a beautiful map
okay i will walk up to you parts street
don't mind me
is nobody concerned that i'm out at
night now that i'm passing adults
you saw it didn't you there it was again
did i miss how old
evan is oh come on or whatever that
spirit wanted it seemed to involve
bringing religion here
but why
to get me rich or die trying
hello
i mean it looks like a shop
but maybe not
[Music]
okay
oh did it go oh okay
i didn't even see it
that looks like the entrance to a pub if
ever i've seen one
okay okay what's up what's the plan
big city life
i must be so glamorous to be so
cosmopolitan you talking about sexes are
you talking about me life's like in the
other zone
i would like to learn about them to town
big city life
i must be so glamorous to be so cosmic
are they cosmopolitan so
two-sided
what about freedom the glory of battle
yours for the taking
i could be a hero there fighters there i
suppose
before the war it was a sight to behold
now though after the queen ruined it
trying to find those
awful rebels the war was so dreadful
i hear everyone works so hard there
it's where the magical cards used to be
made you know
i'm interested to see this card making
i'm assuming that we get to go to all of
them recognized as the best of us it
would be nice
um why do you ask i wasn't born here you
know
i was born in foreberg
turned 12 and the queen came and made me
rule
call myself a one
she told me i was born in the wrong town
and now i'm here oh that's why her
family was happy when it was first on
the one and then it flipped to the six
hmm that's just the way things are
in a way she saved me from the misery of
forbid
it's not what it used to be it doesn't
have to be equal to be fair
that's what my mom always used to say
before she
before i
well that comes at you fast it's uh
ancient history now the queen works in
mysterious ways and it's up to us to
follow her rules
random rules did someone just yell i
still remember how i felt rolling that
dice
knowing what was about to happen
and when it landed on one
course
i don't think it's the sort of thing
i'll ever forget
yeah that's harsh man that is that is
tough i'm haunted enough already
i don't need more of them
see you around i wonder if they had a
world before this whole random thing or
did this particular queen introduce
the entire concept of random rules
but like i can kind of understand it you
know
i don't i fundamentally don't agree with
it but i i you could make cases cases
could be made and clearly she has and
clearly it's all full
so we proved all that wrong just forgot
everything i just said can i climb that
no it's going to have me come down that
surely
that strange figure is this a champion
that her fate was changing oh that her
future was oh that's filled with
unknowns
and she also had the distinct feeling
that she wouldn't be back home for quite
some time i didn't even say goodbye to
my mom
oh no
hello
how are you good good to meet you my
friend
okay
cool
kind of getting uh atlas madness returns
vibes a little bit too which
very good video game
okay
yep
oh no that
oh i'm scared oh okay no just keep your
hands that button
oh boy
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
i i would have left it but all right you
do you we were hey we're all different
people
mysterious playing cards these playing
cards are beautifully painted and in
some angles they seem to glow a faint
blue
pip some curious little pip creatures on
two legs hopping around in a glass jar
interesting okay so
i don't seem to have a way to
look
oh there's going to be a certain amount
of collectible cards side quests wow
this is a very interesting game
even could barely make out what the
ghostly figure was um it was beautiful
my thought is to be a
going to be
a much bigger world than i initially
expected
there was no time to think even was
either going home to her parents without
answers and with even more questions
than before or she was getting on that
boat
she felt a pull yeah towards something
new
something boaty
the character design those are some nice
cards you have how did you see them
where do i have them you find them
yourself all right mate um yes
well heck let me take a look
maybe maybe these old papers will notice
something i love him oh my gosh
well look at these oh these used to be
everywhere you know that
folks had tried them on the regular
quite a collection myself
look i've gone straight from the
factories and five droplets where they
made them you know
i'm very excited about five droplets i'm
gonna be a bunch of artists making cards
up there that sounds great
and i'll change that now okay i'm
guessing we're also we are going to
learn more about the wall with the
consequences
tell me more city of card makers it was
oh it was
oh queen came and
turned it into a city of nightmares
right you won't tell anyone so it won't
actually
be what i want it to be it will folks
got in there be the post-war version of
that opinions like that are treasonous
that's what they call society yep we do
live in a
live in a society
yeah
we've all been there my friend
[Music]
uh oh
i know what those are
um excuse me for a second just gonna
get whatever this is
that i sh and will let me buy things
thank you
interesting okay does this one ever move
onto here
no but that one does
there anything else i should
grab
no think i'm okay
[Music]
oh it won't let me run
i'm under damn it
i thought it was getting shadowed me it
did not
i was super wrong
oh now i'm on the ground okay cool with
it
um how about you can i break you no okay
you
wow
watch yourself watch yourself what is
this
interesting
i feel like i should be collecting
everything and i am not and it's making
me a little bit nervous but that's okay
it's got to be that
i don't seem to be able to
same one makes sense i understand video
games look good as good real gamer
always
[Music]
i do want that
it's that's a card uh i'm doing it i'm
doing it we have to go back down
i'm totally doing it
yeah it doesn't let you jump off the
ledges except for when you're prompted
with the
with the a
um but i'm gonna do it
and i'm excited about it nope nope nope
nope nope
back you go
yeah oh
okay
i'm excited
okay
i don't think it ever comes far enough
we're all right we're all right we're
all right
this is a card storybook page
oh
we only oh there are 10 pages total
hmm
trying to guess what this means
well it seems like things were more
positive but then i would think
one of them looks like a hint of a
robbery
um it's almost like we need more of the
book
[Music]
okay
i could go back around i think
and back over here
what's that why is that glowing oh stop
getting distracted damn it
i did in fact get distracted
uh where am i where am i oh
oh back at the very start
oh
i didn't even realize that that spawn
was the same
all right don't you move the other way
come back over here
[Music]
just wait right here
thank you
do that
okay
my bad
okay
[Music]
that one doesn't seem like it's gonna
move but what do i know
what a noise is going on out here no no
no no you don't get to come here
hey what which what if i just want to
chat
god this is cool
these environments are very cool
no go away
uh
who are you why are you snowing away are
you barging in here demanding who i am
i'm even oh i'm even too
even less i bet she gets that a lot but
she gets that all the time this is
herman's hidey hole
my little story chamber my realm of
adolescence that you're not invited in
it's my ticket out of this muddy town
hmm
i mean something that's delightful like
is that a real word if it is i've not
heard of it i believe you herman you
seem like a good
guy you really are just a kid huh yes
sir
well guess what
i myself was a kid once
kid herman i like his performance i also
love him i'm getting out of here
go find your own spot oh my gosh there
are no
come on there's got to be other spots go
find him
i like feel like he's got room for the
love
fine fine new little
little guild tripper
i'll let you in thank you
but before i do we got ourselves some
house rules
one be quiet fair too harsh but fair
don't touch anything
and three be quiet and don't touch
anything i love him okay it's great
he's my new dad replace the old parents
got a new parent everything's all good
[Music]
childhood's easy i don't know what
anyone he's ever worried about
okay
well the moment she'd let herself think
about it even realized she was actually
exhausted tonight alone she'd seen a
ghost run away from yeah wait what
happened to the ghost
oh she's trying to get me on the boat
somewhere finally disregarding to the
unknown heart of random
would she ever return
it didn't matter odd was the only thing
that mattered
with her sister's name on her lips even
fell into a deep slumber
hmm
am i gonna go to like two town or
something now or are we still gonna be
in
one place
oh heck more dreams oh heck
i'm coming
the sound design oh my
oh my god i'm trying so hard
i can only run so far with these tiny
legs with no cough muscles you know
oh wow
hello even your home
it's where you belong
oh my there's no time no time no time
awana is a wanner is a warner is a
wanner when you're right you're right
even
come stay with us do you want some tea
i'm getting bad vibes i don't know about
you but um
why do you need to see her something
seems like i've seen her before listen
to your mother gosh
that's so harsh it's a dangerous world
out there listen to your mother even
stay here
it's safe here oh man we will never
leave you again
not ever i would have not ever even
terrified of this as a kid
we'll always be here even you'll always
be her even her desires are odd it's the
only way she'll learn i kind of love it
though even if you're lost the queen
will find you
okay love you guys
see ya
this really nice we had a nice normal
family chat it's really great for all of
us oh gosh
oh what up hey cutie how you doing
all right please
please i want to go yeah with her
because she's so cool
they can't hurt you anymore
hurt me
no that's not right they never i don't
think they they were denying you your
future
probing you of your true death that's
pretty pretty rude you're finally home
i wonder what her legs are like
like what's the inadequate just based on
that bend i have a lot of leg anatomy
related
questions
today's a difficult day for you
herman what am
to do i hope that we can stay friends
with
with herman because he's the coolest man
i've ever met in my life
this is very creative
i am into it has even lost sight of
herman
she realized she had also lost sight of
her last connection to home
okay still alive i can work with that
as long as i don't land on water i
shouldn't be able to work with that
fine time to remember i don't know how
to speak she hoped desperately that
she'd land somewhere near sixth town i
imagine six town is up
but maybe i don't know
it's just what i imagined
so
oh where is this place not in one craft
anymore cute oh what's this
nothing just glowy stuff
okay
oh my hello there
she couldn't yet understand it but even
had landed in the middle of something
exceptional
past and the magic she could almost
sense in the air wasn't about to give up
its secrets that easily should hit him
no well we'll we'll leave him be we'll
leave him be he's he's just
chilling hate this though still don't
know what these are that i'm collecting
but i have 140 of them so i think
i'm in pretty good shape
hello
sirs gentlemen
i must be the first person to come here
in decades
hello there okay uh i have i have no no
well this is labyrinthine i have no
problem with you sirs
continue standing post you're doing a
fine job
oh wait can you see the map of this area
no damn
i don't know which way to go
i can hear things moving okay
ah
that answers that question
all right
have they moved
did this move is are things moving
where am i
imagining that hello
[Music]
okay
all right cool i don't have a weapon
oh but i'll spawn them through the cards
perhaps oh yes video games
i mean i could try you know try no okay
doesn't work that's cool that's good to
know
oh cute
harsh but fair
ah pressure plates
oh that's gonna be my dice
and this is some kind of dice graveyard
music's great
[Music]
this is very cute
very good animation
okay
i would like to just jump off
uh you're a dice i feel like you'll be
all right but
may have snot
it's very cute
nice
i thought she had a
missing leg there for a second i was
like oh wow they decided not to show
that that's a lot to
unpack it wasn't
hey
um hi are you okay
are you
[Music]
you ever got so scared you just bump
fireworks
it happens to all of us
[Music]
i guess i'm not in any of the actual
districts
okay
well
thanks for saving me back there
you were really
well
heroic
right
okay
talking to a dice
i better get going
you should too this place is really
dangerous
where are we going though
it's cute i'm into it
it's my own little droid friend
okay
oh um i mean i guess you can tag along
uh the more the merrier and then we're
gonna
stand out
okay even keep it together we're talking
to a dice now even
and to yourself
nice not a trap uh
that's the way back though isn't it is
there a way forward
no okay that seems right
she does want to get out
[Music]
hmm
those are mine
you don't just take things from people
the sign's pretty clear
ugh fine you could hold on to them i
guess
just don't
digest them
i feel like we're gonna have
combat with these guys here now okay
i'm sort of excited
but
that doesn't do much does it oh
it does oh oh that's right yes okay so
you have to get the crystals
to activate the dye
see what i can get
okay
um
when throwing dicey you get card tokens
equal to the result that's shown in the
upper right corner of the screen
card tokens activate your cards
leaving the dice mentioned by attacking
something by pressing oh it was clear
ordinary cards and dicey was no ordinary
defense seems good something i think we
can't play that right now he was
awakening
oh i should have done that that would
that would have been a good idea um
you leave by attacking something right
okay
let's
do
[Music]
oh
jump back in
here was that a one again damn it um
i'm still gonna take this order three
that seems great
press x to hack it slash with each
movement the girl in her dice became
more and more inseparable
this is neat
yeah it's it's interesting
didn't understand what was happening to
her and her new dice friend
i don't actually need it yet so
i'm not going to take it that she
understood completely if i can avoid it
oh it expired okay we go we gotta we
gotta play some cards we gotta get cards
happening again
and you gotta hit and we'll run and
we'll dodge
we'll get our energy back
full hand
bow of one let's do the book
and then let's attack with it
okay
is he dead
yeah
nice
and i guess this will just break when it
breaks
up
cool i like it
oh
oh i got a new card neat
cards i wonder what these do
yeah it's pretty exciting we're an
incredible team and as long as i'm going
to be talking to you i should probably
know your name
well let's see if we can find a way out
of this place dicey
oh that seems like a lot oh no
oh just my least favorite thing in the
world oh gosh
oh they're all spidery oh god okay okay
i need your crystals
oh
[Music]
we will take the sword
this guy's just too speedy for me
okay everybody's asleep right now
they're gonna wake up by a shame is
what's happening
he won't even is about to get hit press
b we knew that okay
oh it's like a parry type dodge
oh cool
very cool
very unique combat system i got a full
hand okay
um right now
i want to do the bomb
i don't think nothing will happen
the ice mission hands out one card token
even no let's just let's just get out of
here
and just
hit one of these
or do i have to i think i do actually
have to hit someone
to get out of the dice mention and then
we'll run
away from the bomb
now too far away okay we definitely
could have strategized that better it's
all right next time
learning as we go
it's all good
i don't have anything left to attack you
with huh
i did screw the bomb up though so i kind
of want to try the bomb again which i
can still afford
do that
uh hang on if i cancel this and then run
back will this do it i think it will
and i just got to get them to kind of
run towards me
that should do it
nice
nice very good
ah there is a card store cool
let me okay i already picked up your
head how how do they
i'd be having a headache too that's very
cute right well um we'll have to talk
more later we'll figure that out at some
point let's just focus on surviving yeah
[Music]
oh my
[Music]
oh the other dice here's ah damn it
[Music]
what happened to this place
[Music]
you've gone decades without seeing
anyone like me you won't move until the
dice right dice wheel that comes that's
exciting
that's very cute
[Music]
stay safe
alrighty everyone that seems like a good
place to leave it um i mean not really i
would actually love to play way more of
this but i try to do these first
you know 45 minutes to an hour of
impressions and that seems like a good
place for us to stop um definitely very
into the game i really like the law i
like the art style i'm super into the
gameplay and i feel like it's gonna get
a lot more elaborate the more cards you
collect um which is really exciting i
don't know i think that it's very neat
so a huge thanks to ea for sponsoring
this video thank you to zoink for making
so many cool games i really love the
stuff that they make and if you want to
check out lost in random which comes out
on september 10th you can find a link in
the description below and that is it for
me today everyone i will see you guys
next time bye